Super Mario Bros.
Duck Hunt! Take aim, fire, and save the Mushroom Princess?
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
I'm Joe.
And I'm Sam.
It's a full house ladies and gentlemen
After two episodes of just me and Sean
Doing a little What would you call that Sean?
I'd say it's a fireside chat with Mike and Sean
But now it's a family reunion
Yeah it's a family reunion
The only reason I skip a couple episodes here and there
Is so we can have the chats and then the reunion
He does have to leave us alone every once in a while
It gets a little steamy
Yeah I might be a strange jungle I guess
But I give real good Christmas presents
That's right So can we talk about the fact that Nintendo combined
Super Mario Brothers and Duck Hunt
Okay so they really didn't do that
But like if they did combine those two games
What would they be?
You mean like combine them into like one actual game
Like you're doing them together?
Yeah like one game called Super Mario Brothers Duck Hunt
I'd love to see what we've been talking about
Since I think the first Duck Hunt episode
Because I guess now we have two
Where you have one player playing as Mario
And another player shooting the enemies with the zapper
But all the Koopa things are now birds
Yeah
Or ducks specifically
I always thought they kind of looked like ducks anyway
Turtle ducks Turtle ducks yeah
And then there's like
Is the dog
Is he
Does he laugh at you every time you fall into an endless pit or something?
I think it's like a glitchy nightmare of the mix of the two
Like the dog laughs while you're shooting at the enemies
The mushrooms coming down
The weird things are flying that shouldn't be flying
Sometimes Mario has the gun
Yeah It's like a fever dream
It would actually be funny if Bowser like popped up on the screen
You know
In the same way the dog does
Every time you die And just like giggles and points at you
Like that would be very intimidating of Bowser to do something like that
And the last
The reality of the situation is
Is nowhere near as fun
It could be just a reskin of Gumshoe
I know Mike you talked about that
Yeah I mean
Using the gun to make Mario jump
Would really bring him back to his jump man roots
Jump man jump
As you say as you shoot at the screen
I love saying that
Dance monkey dance
Do you ever shout the commands of the things you're doing
When you play video games?
Mostly I don't think so
Unless I'm playing Hey You Pikachu
For Nintendo 64
Only when I've been trying to do it the normal way
By just pressing the button
And it won't happen correctly
So it's more like an angry thing
You know It's just to express anger
Yeah I definitely know that
When it's like When you're like I hit A
Even though like deep down
You kind of know like Well I probably hit it too late
But you're like telling everyone else in the room
Like I hit it Yeah exactly
Obviously the games weren't combined
And Sean you kind of said that it's sad that they weren't
But you know it's not sad
Because they're two great games
So can we just kind of go around
And maybe Sean you start us off
How do you feel about these two games
Super Mario Brothers and Duck Hunt?
Well they pretty much defined the original experience of owning an NES
And I don't think that that has changed too much
I mean they are still two of the most popular games in video games
So they're classics
And I think that you know
It's a pretty good way to cheaply get people into it
That haven't adopted the system yet
In 88
To just put together this compilation
They're Yeah they're a classic game
What about you Joe?
Well yeah Super Mario Brothers
There's obviously like
Had already set like a high floor
For quality of these Super Mario games
And it really just continues to get better from there
So it's already like the entry level
Into this great series
That's getting better and better
But married with
I mean you all know how I feel about Duck Hunt
I still absolutely love it
I mean it's just so simple
And so like
Really
I'm not even really sure how you would improve on the gameplay of it
I mean they're just two Very
Simple but
Satisfying games to play
Like you said Sean
At the time
You were buying an NES
Those are probably two of the games at the top of your list to buy
So it makes sense as
You know Just from like a selling games standpoint
To bundle them together
Yeah What about you Sam?
I see it as Nintendo kind of
They're not rebranding
But they're just regular branding themselves
As the distributor of these two super successful games
And they're saying this is what the NES is all about
Yeah they're just reminding everybody
Yeah I can see it from a marketing perspective obviously
But Yeah I mean
What everyone talked about
They're both great games for
Very different reasons
But they have this
Such
They have this essence of Nintendo
In them
And Nintendo realizes that
And they're trying to show everyone else that
Yeah I think
I think You know
Because Super Mario Brothers 2
Just came out
And Super Mario Brothers
Is different enough
From Super Mario Brothers 2
That This is like
Totally fine To have both of those games together
It's not like
Super Mario Brothers 2
Was such an improvement
Over Super Mario Brothers 1
That I'd never want to go backwards
Like They're two separate games
But one thing that's interesting here is
Playing Duck Hunt again now
Really points out the
I don't know
The novelty Of Duck Hunt
It doesn't really seem to be part of that original
NES vision anymore
You know There was a time
Where The NES was pitched as like
An entertainment center
It It had the
The zapper And eventually the power pad
And Also a controller
With two ports
And like The family was always gathering around
Now it's
In 88 It's kind of obvious
That the NES is pretty much
Just for video games
Really reminds me of like
When the Wii
First took off
You know It started with like
Wii Sports And
Grandma bowling
And these golf games
And you know Cooking Mama
And then like As the years went on
We got like
The occasional Wii Fit
Or Wii Music
But
Those were just like
Oddities And video games like
Super Mario Galaxy
Were the norm Yeah
You can kind of see
That All of the
The gimmicks Have sort of
Faded away And they
Just like In every
Generation Of a system
Like you know
After a couple months
They stopped making Kinect games
Or iToy games
Or whatever It was just
When it's first party
Like with Nintendo They're
They're trying to
Expand The feature set
By themselves And then like
With these older situations
Like the Kinect
It's sort of like
A licensing mandate
Like you have to
Make sure that it
Uses these features
For it to work
But yeah
Over time Everything just sort of
Goes back to the mean
Of video games
As we know them
So is this like
The ultimate deal
In video gaming
I mean certainly For the time
Right But even
Even nowadays If you were told
You could get an NES
With a Zapper
And Super Mario Bros.
And Duck Hunt On one cart
I feel like
Most video gamers
Would take you up On that offer
Because it depends
On the price How much did it cost
Mike Well you know
I don't have
Like inflation adjusted
But I'm pretty sure
Back then They were charging
200 So that's
Probably pretty expensive
When you adjust
For inflation Yeah I would say so
I mean unless
I don't know
The comparison Of what the launch
Price was But I'm sure
It was a great deal
You bring up
A good point though Sean
Maybe this isn't
The ultimate deal
But the ultimate value
Yes It's such value
I can't wait
To pitch this I think it also
Probably It also probably
Kind of captures
Some parents
That maybe aren't
As aware of Like the other games
That their kids
Are into But like
Everyone's aware Of Super Mario Bros.
And probably Duck Hunt
And if you're not Aware of Duck Hunt
You can kind of Just look at it
And be like Oh that's what it is
You shoot at the screen
So it's like
You know You don't have to
Wonder like
Was it You know
Was it pro wrestling
That they wanted Or was it
You don't have to Like wonder
Like which version
Of all the different
You know
Hundreds of games
Or over a hundred games
That are out at this point
Your kid wants
You just know Like well these are
These are games That everyone knows about
That's a good point though
Joe Because there's
There's the You know
This is all being
Launched by Nintendo of America
This idea of
Repackaging The NES
I don't know
If this one Was the action set
Or not But just this branding
Of the Super Mario Bros.
Duck Hunt Cartridge in one
And there
You know Maybe Instead of Duck Hunt
This might have
Made more sense To a western audience
To have something Like Wild Gunman
I guess
I mean I feel like
Even here though
Like Duck Hunt
Was I mean
The fact that I never heard
Of Wild Gunman Before
Before we reviewed it
Like I think that says
That even western audiences
Preferred Duck Hunt
Yeah I think And they're going into this
With that information
Like this was so many years ago now
Yeah And I think that Duck Hunt
Just comparing Duck Hunt
To Wild Gunman
And Hogan's Alley
All three I think
Are good games But I think Duck Hunt
Is literally just The most accessible
To the most I mean
They're all accessible
But Duck Hunt Is literally
Just shoot the targets
So it's just like
The easiest one
To get your head around Yeah I mean
There's a world Where they paired
The Urban Champion
And Gumshoe
Together As like their
You know That was their
Double pack For the action pack
Oh man
Everybody has
Goatees in that world
If it is
The ultimate deal Though you can't
Forget about Like games
Like 52 and 1
On the NES
Those bootleg carts
That you see at Like shopping malls
So I mean
There is a better deal
Than Super Mario
Brothers Duck Hunt Theoretically
Yeah but I feel like
You kind of have to be
In the know For those sort of things
Like parents aren't
Going out and buying
The 50 and 1 games
Unless like
They really did
A bunch of research
For it You don't know
My parents And they suck though
Too most of those games
Yeah But I always saw like
You know
5,001
Or something like that
At like one of those
Kiosks at the mall
And you just
You know Even as a kid
You're kind of aware
You're like Well what am I going to do
With 5,000 games
Like what What are the 5,000 games
What am I going to do With 2,000 versions
Of Solitaire
Yeah We don't know
Well you know
You guys have had some time
To reflect on these games
We've talked about
Super Mario Brothers In almost every single episode
But hey We're going to talk about it again
And Duck Hunt
It's been a moment So does anyone have
Don't tell me how good
The games are Does anyone have
Like newfound criticisms
On either of these games
Not really
The game is
What it always has been
It's a simple enough concept
That like
And we haven't played
Too many games like it
Since the early days
Because The Zapper
Has sort of fallen off
In popularity
So I think it stands
As it was
Same pros
Same cons
Yeah I think as far as
Duck Hunt It's just kind of like
Frozen in time
It's like That's just
A result of its simplicity
I'm not sure if you asked
About Mario also
But as far as like
I mean I think I could
I could probably
Find criticisms
To Mario Just based on
My knowledge Of future Mario games
And how they improved
But that almost seems
A little unfair Like you know
When I think of Super Mario Brothers 3
I can think like
Well yeah it probably
Would be nice If you could go backwards
In Super Mario Brothers
The original But you know
Little things like that
But It would be nice
To be able to like Throw the hat
And jump on the hat
Yeah And where's Birdo
You didn't get to Birdo
No no no
He's teasing you No I'm also
I'm also
Yeah Oh wow
Who played who In that situation
Yeah shit I don't know You know
The funny thing is
Is I don't even know
If Nintendo knows Of Birdo anymore
Yeah they don't
Why wouldn't they Well like
What's the last thing Birdo's been in
Smash
Really Yeah
As an assist trophy
I think so
But also As a stage hazard
Oh that's right
In the Super Mario Brothers
2 like stage right
Yes Yeah okay
Alright so they
Are aware of Birdo
But maybe they're like
They're not like
You know it's like Waluigi
They're not like Actively participating
In the fanbase's
Desire for more content
Man that makes me so mad
That what they did
To my boy Well until Waluigi
Becomes like The main villain
Of the Super Mario Brothers
Movie coming out
In 2022 Or 2023
Movie We've been talking about
Super Mario Bros.
and Duck Hunt and, you know, it feels weird to just
go right to the Essential Games list here
and what even is the Essential Games list
in an episode like this.
So I told, I mean, this is a surprise
to our audience maybe, but I told the guys
to go ahead and play Super Mario Bros.
2 Japan. I mean, we just played
Super Mario Bros.
2 USA so I figured this is closer
to Super Mario Bros.
and Super Mario Bros.
Duck Hunt is the game of the week.
So what do you guys say we talk a little bit
about Super Mario Bros. 2
for real?
Let's do it. Yeah, I'm okay with that.
I'm more enthusiastic about it,
but Sean's okay with it.
Well, that's good because, you know,
there's only, thankfully, there's only like
some small game design
differences that, you know,
I think we should talk about, but this isn't
like a whole in-depth thing that we need to do.
You know, there is no two-player mode
in this game. You just choose between
Mario and Luigi.
And I thought that that's kind of interesting
because Super Mario Bros.
not having a two-player mode was like,
I never really cared about the two-player mode
anyway since you just split them up.
But this actually has like Mario
like retain most of his abilities
from Super Mario Bros.
but now Luigi gets the ability to jump higher
than Mario can.
And this decision was made before
Super Mario Bros.
USA came out.
Super Mario Bros. 2 Japan
came first.
So it's almost like this is the first instance
of Luigi having a high jump.
Wow. And I just,
I genuinely didn't even think twice.
When it boots up
and it gets to the title screen
and just says Mario game
and Luigi game,
I didn't even think of the implications
of that. But like,
I would have just thought that
you just played as green Mario.
I really didn't know
that there was a gameplay difference
between them. Is there an advantage
to being Mario? So,
Luigi does have a downside
and that is that
he cannot stop his momentum
as quickly as Mario.
So if you are running
as Luigi,
you kind of, you know,
like you can't just be speed running through
because it's harder to stop.
And so a lot of times you'll just run into the pit
when you thought you might have like
hit the jump button
or stopped.
So it almost feels,
because I, like Sean,
I also didn't know that there was a difference.
I just played as Mario.
But it almost seems like
then you would play as Luigi
once you're really good
at the game and you want to jump higher
and move faster and kind of get through
the level quicker. But like,
if you're just starting out,
you play it safe and play as Mario?
I don't know. To me,
that seems to be the case.
Like, Luigi is who you'd use
to speed run. Yeah,
he feels almost like an expert player's mode,
you know, because I did try Luigi out
and to be honest,
you would think in a game like
Super Mario Brothers, who cares if you can jump higher?
But that does prove
pretty useful given the new way
that they design levels
in this game, which we'll get into
in a minute. But the trade-off
and the skidding
taking longer
and such
made this really difficult
for someone who plays
Super Mario Brothers like I do,
where they're always
holding down the run button
and then using,
like, the other side of their thumb
to jump. Made it really hard
to play this game successfully
because chances are
you're just gonna keep knocking into enemies
and losing any power-ups
or your lives
that you have. Yeah,
definitely the terrain
is, like,
more dangerous in this game
than in the original. Yeah,
there's just an abundance
of hidden blocks,
an abundance of enemies,
the platforms
in between,
like, the gaps
are smaller.
Sometimes they're, like, very precise
where it's just, you know,
an area big enough for Mario or Luigi.
so there's just,
like, more traps
and deaths in general.
And I don't know,
like, is that,
is that how you would
improve a game
by making it harder?
Well, I mean, I feel like I'm,
you may have described it
like this in a prior episode
where we just sort of tangentially talked about
this version of the game,
but it kind of plays
like a ROM hack.
Like, it doesn't feel like
there's any friendliness
in the design of this game.
It's really just,
like, the,
the expert mode
of Super Mario Brothers
because it really is
a frustrating experience
at some points
in this game. Yeah,
I agree with that totally.
I was going to say
it almost plays like a Mario Maker thing,
but I like the ROM hack
analogy even better.
And not even just
on a gameplay level,
but even in some cases
on, like, a design decision level.
Like, the biggest one
that stands out to me is, like, the squids
that were exclusively
underwater because they're squids
in the other games
are just, like, floating around
in the air. Like, it just feels like
someone was like, oh, I'll just put the squids
with those physics here in midair.
Like, it felt, they definitely still have,
like, a lot of attention
to how they're designing
the level to make it play
like a good level,
but it seems like
they just stopped caring about,
like, context
in some cases
and they're just like, ah, just throw things
wherever it makes it hard.
Like, don't make it
make too much sense.
Yeah, I guess, like,
the game, it sort of treats you
more like an adult
in the way that it's not
hand-holding you,
but in some ways
it can be really ambiguous
and, like, the three most,
uh, like,
illustrative parts of this game
that I played
are one,
yeah, that, um,
the squids being in midair,
uh, which seems
kind of cheap to me,
uh, there was a part
where there was
like a, in,
an un-jumpable chasm
that you had to just
search for a hidden
block to be able to get,
to get around.
World 2-2,
Sean. Um,
and then
3-4,
which is just
messing with you
and you can just
keep running to the
right and it's just gonna keep looping
unless you take a specific path.
But to be fair, that was in the
original Super Mario
and that was also
one thing I didn't care for then.
Was that in the first?
Yeah. It was in the
8-4, yeah.
Yeah. I hated that.
Well, I didn't like that.
Yeah, that's where I stopped playing
in this one, actually.
Yeah, that's kind of where I stopped
playing here. The game in general,
though, feels like Nintendo's
just angry that
people were good
at Super Mario
Brothers because,
you know what's really strange
is when you get
to World 1-2
and, of course,
by now, everybody knows
about the warp zones,
so you go to
the warp zone and there's
like a few
treacherous pipes with
piranha plants
and then you do eventually get to
the real warp zone
and it takes you
just to the next
one, World 2.
There's no choice
between 2, 3,
and 4. You just get one
and that's actually true for all the
warp zones in the game.
There's only ever one warp zone.
However, in some of those
warp zones, they will send you
back to the very
beginning of the game.
Yep. I came across that.
That's just like,
it is,
they're just like, they're screwing with us.
Yeah. They're just messing
with us at this point.
You were skillful enough
to get up here
and now here's your
punishment. Yeah,
it's like you see the thing that's like,
oh, I bet there's a secret
up there. You see whatever clue
there is and then they punish you
for exploring that
way. Even early on,
I think it's
World 1-2, there's an obstacle
where you can be
Super Mario,
so you're bigger, and you might have
defeated all the enemies on the
screen, but the blocks
aren't, like,
they're too low, so you won't be
able to, like, run underneath
them or anything, but also there's
no enemies on the
screen to make
yourself small Mario
and fit under it.
So you have to
kind of figure out on your own
that you need, like,
a running start
and then press
down and kind
of, like, glitch through
the underground
part of the cave.
And I don't know,
like, that,
it is a, it's a super
player move, like,
people who are good at the game
probably know that exists,
but I think now it's,
yeah, now it's, like,
an actual mechanic
that you have to use because it's,
it kind of pops up
in a lot of spots,
especially if you're
looking for, like,
secret blocks,
um, which are usually
hidden under those
columns of,
uh, breakable, uh,
like, when you're in the underground levels,
like, those break blocks,
um, like,
it's, it's a move that you have to do
pretty often if you
want to do it that way.
And so maybe it's a
good idea that they put it early on
just so that it's
something you learn, you either learn or
you never learn, and you're just like,
what the heck, like, I suck at this game
or I need to be
small Mario, but maybe it was a
good thing if they were planning on making
that, like, a core mechanic of
the game. I just,
I don't know, something,
something's wrong about
the fact that the
major improvements of
Super Mario Bros. 2
are focused around
making it harder for
you. There's, there's the new
poison mushroom,
that when you touch
one, it either automatically
kills you or makes
you smaller. There's,
uh, and that's likely the
first thing you're going to come across.
Like, I, you're going to
probably miss the
first, like, real mushroom in
1-1, like,
like I did at least.
Um, and then you,
like, the first obvious
pickup is a
mushroom that doesn't look quite right,
and then you pick it
up and you die, because you didn't get
that big mushroom. So that,
they're just sort of telegraphing to you
that, like, this isn't going to
be friendly. Yeah.
Well, there's even a point
where there's a,
there's like a platform of,
you know, of, of blocks,
of coin blocks
that you're
underneath, and it's long
enough that you, you move the
screen far enough that you can't go
back out from
under it, and right in the
middle is a
fire flower. I guess it,
I guess it is dependent on if
you're small, it would still be
helpful, but, um,
but right in the middle there's a
fire flower, but in order to get
to it, you have to go all
the way to the right to get out
from under the block, and you have
to go out to the point where
it's off the screen. It's literally
just something that's, it just shows
you it's there and it's
possible, impossible to
get. Uh,
granted, now that I'm
explaining it, I do realize
that if you're small, I forgot,
you would still get a mushroom
out of that, so I guess it's
not completely useless.
Did any of you
get to the,
uh,
the strong wind,
uh, levels where,
like, the, the leaves are
blowing and
Mario, it's like there's
resistance against
him moving forward?
If it was after
3-4 that I didn't
I saw some
footage of it and I actually
thought that was the first thing
that I thought, like, oh, this looks like
a, something that
makes it harder in more of a
gameplay improvement
way rather than
like a, just annoying,
like, deliberately, like,
frustrating way. Yeah,
something like that is,
is a really cool
addition to the
game because that's actually
changing, like,
how you, how you tackle
a stage, like, you need to
always be moving forward or else,
it's almost like a reverse auto-scroller.
Like, you need to always be
moving forward, otherwise it's gonna
push you back. Right,
right, yeah, I would like to see more of that,
you know, because they, you know, adding more little,
like, physics mechanics
that are, I don't know,
a little more
variety than what
we saw in the first game.
They play with physics a little
bit though because there's also that
super spring,
which just, like,
you have no idea where you are on
screen once you
jump on it. I just kind of,
like, I saw it happen
and I'm like, is this,
like, is this supposed to
happen? Like, is this game
haunted? Like, I didn't know
what was happening. Well,
when I first did it, I had the star
and I thought,
like, oh, is that a thing
in the original Mario
that if you have the star and go off a
spring, you just fly,
like, into the heavens?
No, I guess all those
springs do that. And I think that
spring one is actually
the first example,
Joe, that we were talking
about with the warp zones where
you'll use the
spring and you'll go so high that
you fly over the
first goal post and
all of a sudden you
wind up in the warp zone area that
sends you back to the beginning of the
game. Is that right? Is that the one
you remember? Yes.
Yeah, that's right. I forgot about it.
I just said it's so funny.
It's like, oh, you missed the
goal post, go back to the
beginning of the game. Yeah,
because it's so
enticing. It's like, look,
you can get past the goal post,
like, and I'm like, oh, what secrets are
over here? And then it's
like, don't explore. Yeah.
So since none of
us beat this game,
I'll be honest and
just say, like, I had a good time
playing it, but I knew there
was no way I was going to beat it.
I think there's
some things you guys
need to know about
the length of
Super Mario Bros. 2.
Okay. Japan. So after you beat
Super Mario Bros.
2 Japan without
using anything,
any warp zones,
you go to
World 9-1,
the fantasy world.
Oh. Is that legal?
I didn't think
you could count above 8.
So there's an
extra world, World 9,
and it tells you
pretty much, like, there's a new
prompt on the
screen that you're
only going to get
one life.
You only have one life,
regardless of how
many lives you ended World 8-4 with.
You only have
one life to get
through all of
World 9-1,
9-2, 9-3,
and 9-4. Do you not
save the princess in World 8?
You do, but now you're in
like this fantasy
world. Gotcha. Where it's just
like, do it again,
one more time. Okay,
man, I'm watching it now,
and it actually does give you
a quick,
some quick info,
which, it's interesting,
you don't really, you don't really
see that very often
with Mario.
Yeah, what does it say? Do you know
what it says? It says,
we present
fantasy world,
let's try
9 world
with one game.
Okay, I like how
they're calling it game instead of
life. Yeah.
Maybe they
hadn't adopted
the lives term yet
in game terminology,
but that's interesting.
Hmm. However,
it doesn't end
there, guys. It doesn't end
at World 9.
Oh, dear. Should you
be really good
at Super Mario
Brothers 2 Japan
and are looking
for the ultimate
challenge, you need to,
without resetting
or shutting off
the console, you need to beat
Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan
8 times
in a row.
And every single
time you beat the game,
it adds a star
to the main menu
logo where it says
Super Mario Brothers.
Once you see
8 stars,
you'll be able
to unlock worlds A
through world
D. What?
Oh my god. So that's another
16 levels.
Do you have to keep the console on?
Sorry, I heard two
questions there. Do you have to
keep the console on for this
whole time? It does not
save. Yeah, right.
So who has
that much time
or electricity
bills? It's so much
worse than something like Ghosts and
Goblins, too, because Ghosts and
Goblins is like you're just playing the game
again for the
most part, where this is
like there is
content locked
behind you
beating the game
eight times in a
row. There's like tons
of content that
you'll never see
unless you're willing to commit
that time. It sounds like
one of those
April Fool's
jokes that a gaming magazine
would put out
because it
doesn't sound feasible.
I'm actually watching a
world A
through D warpless
speedrun right now.
These levels
don't look that crazy,
but the fact that they're locked behind
this ridiculous
feat is
amazing. I don't know.
Yeah, you're right though.
It sounds like playground
talk. Do you know
if you beat the game eight times
there'll be 16 more
levels? Exactly.
This is where
Goku and
Smash started
because things like this
actually happened.
However, I have to
mention, because I'm
sure somebody who's listening
knows, I was
incorrect Super Mario
Brothers 2 Japan was
for the Famicom
disc system,
so it can write
to the disc every
time you beat the game,
but it doesn't let
you save
in the
middle of your game, so you
do need to beat
it completely
eight times.
Which you could do
over the course of
owning a game for
a while. Especially
after you beat a
game once, you have
a better shot of beating it
ever again. There's no
game that people beat
that they can't beat again.
Yeah,
and this is obviously a lot harder
than the
original Super Mario Brothers,
but the way people were
with the original Super Mario Brothers,
people beat
that in a sitting all
the time. Well,
I haven't. Well,
neither have I, but I know
people have. You guys have
never beat the original Super
Mario Brothers? I've beaten it,
but not like speed ran it,
like I'm talking
about. I've never
beaten it. I'm terrible
at these
platformers. I play them
and enjoy
them, but I
need the
ease that
comes with the later
generations. I've beat a
lot of PlayStation games.
I've barely beaten any
NES games.
Honesty is good here,
Sean. Yeah. Sean,
me too. I've never
beaten Super
Mario Brothers. Good to know
I'm not alone. So the last
thing about the Worlds
A through D is I
just had to find out.
I was like, okay, so what could
World D4
even look
like? How challenging
could it be? And other
than a series
of very strange
design decisions,
the most interesting thing
about World
D4 is that
there's a fake
Bowser. He actually
has a slightly
different sprite,
and the fake
Bowser shows up
first, and you run
past him, and you think
you're in the
clear, and then the
real Bowser Bowser is
behind a
small little
opening that
he can clearly shoot fireballs
under, and then there's
also in that small opening
there's a fire wheel
attached to
it that rotates
around. So the
moment of
precise,
the precision
that it requires
to get under
Bowser, you have to wait for him
to jump, you have to
wait for the fire wheel
to be in the right place, you most
likely have to be small Mario,
like there's no,
you have to slide as
well to be big Mario,
it's just there's so many
things working against you,
it feels like it doesn't want
you to beat
the game. Oh yeah,
I kind of get that.
Okay, so I'm watching in
this run right now, he ran
past fake
Bowser. Who's like a
goofy character, just like a fake
Bowser, who knew? I couldn't even
tell the
difference in the sprite there.
He's like bluer or
something? Yeah, this is a
pan. Yeah, he's bluer,
yes. Wow,
yeah, he is bluer.
Fun, not fun,
not fun at all
actually. And I think
there's like a, there's a nice
message though for
beating that one,
but, you know,
it does kind of
feel a little strange that
all of this is
hidden behind like beating a
game eight times, but I guess
that's the mystery
of these, of these older
games, you know, it was like
he said, she said kind
of thing. Yeah,
it's strange, but it is
definitely really cool.
Like, I would have, I would have
been fascinated by it when I
was a kid. Now a lot of
the like wonder is taken out of
it by the fact that we can
just look it up and see what
it all is. It's like, oh,
it's just more levels. But like,
I would have been fascinated by what could
come next. Let me just
tell you what it says when
you beat the game like
this. Please.
Peace is paved with
kingdom saved.
Hurrah to Mario,
our only hero.
This ends
your trip of
a long friendship.
100,000
points added. Oh,
thank God. I really needed
those points here at the
end of the game. It had like a
nice structure going for it,
and then it's just like 100,000
points to Gryffindor.
100,000 points
for each player left.
Super Mario!
that's All right, so you want some development info on Super Mario Bros.
2? Let's go. All right, so here's a quote from Howard Phillips.
You'll remember him as the guy who played every NES game for Nintendo of America
and was in, like, the Howard and Nestor comics.
We talk about him all the time, so I'm not going to say anything else.
He says,
As I continued to play,
I found that Super Mario Bros.
2 asked me again and again to take a leap of faith
and that each of those leaps resulted in my immediate death.
This was not a fun game to play.
It was punishment.
Undeserved punishment.
I put down my controller astonished that Mr.
Miyamoto had chosen to design such a painful game.
I love it.
And many people believe that's why Super Mario Bros.
2 never came. And instead, they requested a separate Super Mario Bros.
2 that, you know, we covered a few episodes back.
America isn't ready for that kind of sadism.
Yeah. I mean, it does seem like this game is just not for, like, the masses.
This is for people who are, like, really, really hardcore original Mario players that really want a challenge.
Yeah, you have, like, two different viewpoints here.
On one side, Miyamoto is quoted as saying that, like, they just had, like, all these additional ideas that they wanted to use in Super Mario Bros.
that they just didn't have time to implement for the release.
So then they just made Super Mario Bros.
2, which they didn't quite see as, like, a totally new game.
Just taking all the ideas that they couldn't put into Super Mario Bros.
1, just put it in the next game.
And brand it out and get that out there.
And then you have Tezuka saying that he didn't like that, you know, the Japanese players had mastered the original game.
And so he felt like they needed a more challenging sequel.
Like, that the Mario brand wasn't going to succeed if everybody was able to beat these games all the time.
Oh, okay. I thought, again, I thought he was just, like, trying to put them in their place.
He kind of did.
He said, you mastered the original game.
How about pure pain, according to Howard Phillips?
And as far as sequels and spinoffs go, this came out for both Super Mario All-Stars and Super Mario Bros.
Deluxe. All-Stars on Super Nintendo, Deluxe on the Game Boy.
In both of those, you can save whenever you want.
So that definitely makes it a little less challenging.
However, you can't really, like, play it in Super Mario Bros.
Deluxe. You need to get 300,000 points in Super Mario Bros.
Deluxe to unlock Super Mario Bros.
for Super Players.
They renamed it?
They renamed it.
They didn't want to call it Super Mario Bros.
2 because, well, there was a game in America called Super Mario Bros.
2. So they called it Super Mario Bros.
for Super Players. And to be honest, I agree with that title.
I mean, I was always fond of it, like, the lost levels, just because I had All-Stars.
And I liked that it was just sort of this weird, like, artifact of something that I had never heard about before.
And, like, even the box shape was different in the menu when you chose your game.
When you chose your game.
So, I prefer lost levels.
You know, there's also this game called Versus Super Mario Bros.
And it is different.
So we may very well have to play that sometime.
Yeah, during the next bundle.
Yeah, during Super Mario Bros.
2 and Duck Hunt 2.
You're waiting for Duck Hunt 2.
I'm waiting. It's coming soon.
I'm glad you brought up Super Mario Bros.
and Duck Hunt, though, Joe, because we have a loose end.
We have to go to the Essential Games list where we will not be voting on Super Mario Bros.
2 Japan. But instead, we'll be voting on Super Mario Bros.
slash Duck Hunt.
This is the Essential Games list.
Okay, Sam.
What do you got?
What's your vote?
And before you vote too confidently, I want to throw in an additional piece of the Essential Games list here.
I'd also just, I'd like to hear, you know, your vote on if Super Mario Bros.
2, which is ineligible.
But let's pretend like it was.
Would you put it in the Essential Games list?
Hmm. Should I answer that first?
You give them to me in any order.
Surprise me. Hmm.
It's 10.34 in the morning.
I'm taking a shower and I'm listening to the NostalgiaCast episode.
The new one that just came out today.
Gotcha. And you're about to tell me your vote.
Well, I think that, I don't know, but I think that for Super Mario Bros.
2 Japan, part of me wants to throw it on the Essential Games list.
Because it gives you so much extra stuff at the end of it.
And it is really hard.
And it's like a, you know, it's like Ocarina of Time Master Quest sort of vibes.
Like, you know, Lost Levels, that whole deal.
But it's, but it also seems, like you guys said, like more like a fan game.
That it's like not really, it's like a little bit less real than what a Super Mario Bros.
game would be.
Um, so I'm not going to put it on the Essential Games list for that reason.
I think it's really interesting, but I think that if you want a Super Mario Bros.
experience, that this one is very, it's like Super Mario Bros.
1, but just with other stuff in it that makes it fun sometimes,
but sometimes less enjoyable.
But I think it does not deserve a spot.
All right. And how about Super Mario Bros.
Duck Hunt? Super Mario Bros.
Duck Hunt? Well, I mean, if we add it, then do we add, do we get rid of Super Mario Bros.
and Duck Hunt? Or are we going to have all of them on there?
I guess what I'm trying to tell you is that it really doesn't matter.
Right. The games are already on the Essential Games list.
So this is just you getting a chance to put them on it again.
Right. This is just me talking to myself in circles.
Yeah, it's not like they actually get added twice.
Right. Then, I don't know.
I would say yes, because for the people who were kind of late to the NES game,
this is probably a really great incentive to get it.
And it's also like just having both of them be so accessible is, I don't know.
I think it's really cool that they're able to cram both those games.
Cram. They're probably like four kilobytes or something.
But, you know, cram those games onto one cartridge.
And also something I didn't say.
Yeah. I'm a little bit nostalgic.
Not nostalgic.
I already messed it up.
Nostalgic for this one because this is actually the first NES game I've ever played.
was the combo game, Duck Hunt and Super Mario Brothers.
That's the game we're playing.
Yeah. So, I enjoyed being able to switch back and forth without having to, you know, go over to
the NES and move things around.
And I don't know.
I think it provides a slightly different experience.
And it's more optimized than playing the game separately.
Cool. Well said. And Joe, how about you?
All right. I'll start with Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan as well, just because it's the one that I have
a better idea of how to answer.
So, I do think there's a weird, like, element to this because if you really think about it
logically and take out what we know about video game sequels, it makes a lot of sense that
the sequel to Super Mario Brothers 1 is just the same thing, but it's just gotten harder.
Just like, you know, each level got harder in Super Mario Brothers 1.
Now you continue. It gets harder and harder from there.
I don't think that that ends up being necessarily a good video game sequel just because, A, because
it's not what we're used to, and B, because I think we want to have that progression again.
We want to start from scratch again and progress for the most part.
There's the element of there being so much, of it feeling like a fan-made game or a ROM hack
that does make it feel a little less accessible to the masses, I guess.
And it just feels like something that's essential if you're, it's an essential game for a Mario
fanatic who really wants to just play more Mario.
I don't think it's essential for everyone.
It's hard for me to put it there, and I think there are too many things that are just deliberately
frustrating or, like, I do think it's kind of poor game design to entice you to go, to
spend a whole earlier game enticing you to kind of explore and find secrets, and then kind
of spend this game punishing you for that in some ways, and doing things that just like,
oh, you just have to know that this hidden block is here to progress, and things like that.
Um, I think, I think hurt it and keep it off the essential games list for me.
Um, as far as Super Mario Duck Hunt, I mean, I think that Super Mario and Duck Hunt both
separately still 100% belong in the essential games list, and like, I don't really feel like I have a
horse in the race if the combo goes on there.
Like, I think if you want them both, like, that's a great thing to have on there.
Kind of have a cop-out answer here.
I think it just, yeah, it's kind of arbitrary whether or not the combo goes on there.
I'd say, yeah, let's put it on there.
You don't have to switch cartridges.
That's really the only upside.
Okay, I'm gonna go next.
I'm gonna go next.
Uh, I was under the impression that this vote was purely ceremonial, and it was just going
to put this off the essential games list, and I have too much, I feel too much for the
sanctity of the essential games list to put this cart on there, uh, just because it has
two essential games on it.
It's, no. It's not the, it's not the game.
Well, to be clear, I think you're right.
I don't think this is actually going on the essential games list.
Well, there's two votes now.
I think we're all on the same page here.
There's two votes. Yeah, but I thought that this was just like you said, uh, this is a, you know, just an exercise.
Joe, Joe, Joe, you can't talk back now.
I forgot. It's what you did.
I've given up my, uh, my...
You've done what you've done.
So, I'm, I'm throwing my weight behind keeping it off.
Uh, so, yeah, no, essential for the, for the combo pack.
Uh, as for Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan, um, I, like, I think that we have thankfully
moved on on what a sequel is supposed to be, and even before this, uh, in, in North American,
uh, view of things, like, we kind of saw what a sequel kind of should be, uh, which is a,
an evolution of a game, um, an evolution of a property as opposed to an expansion pack.
This is an expansion pack.
I do not think it's essential, uh, especially, and if, if it's just for the hardcore, I think
that by itself makes it unessential.
So, that, those are my, that's my figurative vote for that.
All right.
So, here's the deal.
Super Mario Brothers slash Duck Hunt makes sense for every person who owns an NES.
In fact, only really snooty video game collectors should buy them separately, like, to preserve
the individualness of them.
Like, anybody who's smart would just buy this cart for, like, 99 cents because it was made
for millions of copies.
Just buy this one, and now you have two great games, or you could pay, like, $8 for Super
Mario Brothers and, I don't know, maybe $12 for Duck Hunt, and it's, it's, like, congratulations.
You own them both separately.
Uh, if you got them with the boxes, it's, like, hundreds of dollars.
So, hope you feel good there.
Where, instead, most people are going to go the route of the Super Mario Brothers Duck
Hunt cart, uh, combo cart.
However, I am not going to make my essential games list filthy and put a cartridge, you
know, put a scan of a cartridge that has both of these games in half.
I want them to be full.
So, for that, I'm a snooty collector, and I'm going to keep Super Mario Brothers Duck
Hunt off the essential games list.
Hold on a second. I feel cheated here, because you said at the beginning of this that this would not really
go on our essential games list.
No, no, no. We were talking about, now I'm being, you know.
Well, Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan would not go on the essential games list.
What's that? You were saying that Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan wouldn't go on the essential games list.
No, I thought you were saying that these are both kind of just, uh, ceremonial votes,
like, should they be considered essential?
I want the listeners to know every minute of nostalgia matters.
There's never a moment where we shouldn't be listening.
Uh, this is, this is 100% serious.
Joe, I understand where you're coming from.
Of course we wouldn't have put, like, four different, you know, like, because this is
going to come up again. There's a Super Mario Brothers Duck Hunt world-class track meet, you know?
Oh, good. I have another chance.
I was, I thought that was unclear because I could have sworn that we were, we were actually
voting for Super Mario v.
Duck Hunt. Well, we, we were.
I, I, I feel like we're in a confusing realm where I'm saying we are and we are not at the
same time. But everybody gets what I'm saying, right?
Like, everyone understands.
We're voting out of ceremony.
No! No, I don't understand.
No, no, no, it's fine.
I'm just trying to be funny.
And on the other side, just to wrap this thing up, you know, Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan
is a less special version of Super Mario Brothers 1.
If this game came first, Super Mario Brothers would not have been as big a hit.
Still would have been revolutionary for its time.
Probably would have still been, like, you know, the thesis of many future games.
But it would have set a pretty bad design precedent for the industry if Super Mario Brothers 2 Japan
was the only Super Mario Brothers.
And so I'm really glad that this is the expansion pack that Sean described it as because that
is exactly what it is.
And I'm fine with that, you know?
That's, if you're a super player and you're looking for more Super Mario Brothers, heck,
if you just like Super Mario Brothers and you're looking for more Super Mario Brothers,
this isn't a bad game.
It's just not really, like, it's not what I think of when I think of the Super Mario Brothers
core games.
And so for that reason, it's staying off.
Yeah. And we are going to be signing off.
I have no idea what we're playing next week.
Do any of you guys know?
Oh, Super Team Games.
I can't believe. So we should all, we should, you know, get our Super Teams together.
And we'll face off in the next episode.
We'll be right back.